Some superhero cartoons have multiple seasons
to tell their story, while others end abruptly,
often on cliffhangers, left eternally unresolved.
Here are the real reasons these animated superhero
shows were canceled, although in many cases,
knowing why won't make their absence any easier.
Virgil Hawkins is that most classic of superheroes
a normal kid until he suddenly very much isn't.
Transformed by exposure to a mutagen gas,
he gains the ability to control electromagnetism
and becomes Static, hero of Dakota City.
And alongside his best friend, Richie, he
spent four seasons of Static Shock battling
bad guys, learning life lessons, and occasionally
hanging out with Shaquille O'Neal.
"What's up, little man?
You must be-"
"Shaq."
"No, I'm Shaq.
You gotta be Virgil.
I've heard a lot about you."
Fans flocked to it.
Static Shock earned high ratings from the
very beginning, to the point of surpassing
all other kids' shows save global juggernaut
Pokemon.
Nor did these ratings slacken with time.
Reruns aired on Cartoon Network outstripped
all other children's programming.
What, then, put a halt to Static's crackling
popularity?
Well, it was something that had nothing to
do with ratings: merchandising.
As creator Dwayne McDuffie recounted years
after the show's end, animation is enormously
expensive to produce, and it depends upon
the success of multiple revenue streams.
A well-rated cartoon must also have profitable
toys, T-shirts, video games, and tie-in books,
which Static Shock lacked.
Sadly, toy companies weren't as keen on the
cartoon as kids were.
McDuffie explained to The World's Finest:
"After five years, we had a Subway value meal,
two Scholastic book adaptations, one DVD,
and a Gameboy Advance game."
Being able to do as many episodes as they
did was, quote, "a gift" one that fans the
world over were ecstatic to receive.
Teen Titans' slick style, unforgettable theme
song, and clever twists on superheroic tropes
dazzled fans right off the bat.
Created to appeal to younger viewers, it was
goofy, though nowhere near the levels of its
successor, Teen Titans Go!, approachable to
comics newbies, and with its anime-inspired
aesthetic, it was unlike any other superhero
cartoon then on the air.
Though the series' final episode aired in
January 2006, fan campaigns to resurrect Teen
Titans continue to thrive online.
Their passion is real...yet so is the series'
demise.
"As long as we're still here, we still have
a chance.
And that's why we're going to keep fighting."
What stopped Robin and his merry band of adolescent
avengers?
A variety of explanations have been offered
over the years.
Wil Wheaton, voice of Aqualad, asserts that
Warner Brothers executives were unimpressed
by the sixth season's pitch.
Story editor Rob Hoegee, however, has gone
on record as saying that it was a decision
made by Cartoon Network instead of Warner
Brothers, and that the crew knew that the
fifth season would be the show's last.
Producer and writer David Slack has suggested
two additional reasons as to why the show
ended.
First, it might've been because ratings dropped
after Teen Titans' dark fourth season, or
it might've been thanks to a dispute over
toy licensing.
As Bandai had the show's toy deal and Cartoon
Network switched entirely to working with
Mattel in 2006, that theory, at least, has
some degree of evidence behind it.
No one reason for the Titans' demise may ever
emerge, yet their end remains resolutely in
place, much to the frustration of long-time
fans.
Released in 2013, Beware the Batman is unique
within the Caped Crusader's animated history.
Rendered in sleek CGI, Beware's Batman fights
alongside a significantly more spry Alfred
and Katana here imagined to be Alfred's goddaughter
against lesser-known Bat-baddies like Anarky,
Professor Pyg, Magpie, and Phosphorus Rex.
A shake-up to be sure, but one built on a
solid foundation.
As series producers Glen Murakami and Mitch
Watson explained, Beware the Batman was meant
to be a return to the character's roots as
a detective.
It had potential, talent, and vision, and
yet it was pulled from Cartoon Network's schedule
a mere three months after its premiere.
An official explanation wasn't offered, and
the series was moved to Adult Swim's Toonami
block.
There it stayed, until the only thing resembling
an announcement was made by Toonami's official
Tumblr blog:
"Bad news: We JUST (like, hours ago) found
out from our legal department that Beware
the Batman...[is] being 'written off,' financially,
as of now."
Toonami aired the final seven episodes of
the series on September 28, 2013, and that
was that.
Other than that brief mention of financial
failure, no further explanation has arrived,
reruns are rare, and Batman fans must get
their animated fix via Justice League Action
and DC's slate of direct-to-video films.
Beware the Batman is well on its way to becoming
much like its titular hero: a half-remembered
phantom, shrouded in mystery, hearsay, and
rumor.
Young Justice delighted fans the world over
when, years after its 2013 cancellation, it
returned for a third season, Young Justice:
Outsiders.
But why was it cancelled in the first place?
One explanation came from Kevin Smith's Fat
Man on Batman podcast.
In conversation with animation legend Paul
Dini, the two men claimed that network executives
were unsatisfied with Young Justice's high
female viewership, as, quote, "they don't
buy toys."
Series developer Greg Weisman denied this,
however.
Three years after the show's untimely end,
he identified Young Justices' weak toy sales,
unrelated to gender, as the cancellation culprit.
"Well now, you're everything I like best in
a woman.
An easy target."
Crowdfunding efforts sprung up in the wake
of the show's cancellation, but Warner Brothers
made it clear that they weren't interested
in furthering Young Justice in that way.
Yet somehow, things changed.
Young Justice's arrival on Netflix stirred
up enough attention that rumors began to circulate
about a possible continuation rumors that
Weisman eventually legitimized.
He urged fans to keep making noise, and eventually,
it was enough, and Young Justice returned
to its eager fanbase.
For some fans, dreams do come true...if your
Netflix debut produces big enough numbers,
anyway.
Consisting of just 13 episodes, Spider-Man
Unlimited was canceled before it managed to
air even half of its modest run.
It wasn't miserable to look at, nor were its
ratings poor.
What slew this spider?
A few different things, as it turns out.
To begin with, the premise was strange.
This cartoon follows a Peter Parker stranded
on "Counter-Earth," where he fights alongside
J. Jonah Jameson's son against the forces
of the High Evolutionary.
Marvel wasn't pleased with this complex plotting,
but in fairness, the cartoon was looking far
afield of traditional Spider-Man stories because
it had to.
"Something funny is going on here.
My spider-sense is going full blast!"
Spider-Man Unlimited was made by Saban Entertainment,
who had, in the wake of Sony and Marvel's
deal to produce Sam Raimi's Spider-Man film,
been cut off from using Spider-Man's familiar
iconography and story beats.
The final blow, however, came from an entirely
different direction.
Fox Kids, then, quote, "dealing with the realities
of Pokemon as a competitor," didn't have faith
in Spider-Man Unlimited's ability to take
on Pikachu.
Thus ended what just might be the weirdest
Spider-Man cartoon of them all, slain by Ash
Ketchum, movie rights, and overworked plotting.
The Silver Surfer cartoon was a blink-and-you'll-miss
it affair, the sort of footnote even die-hard
Marvel partisans might not know about.
A blend of cel-shading, computer animation,
and Jack Kirby's sensational style, Silver
Surfer: The Animated Series has only 13 episodes
to its name, but boy, does it throw everything
it can into those five-ish hours of storytelling.
Characters like Beta Ray Bill and Uatu the
Watcher populate the show's cosmic confines,
alongside figures two decades' shy of superstardom,
like Thanos and Gamora.
It's big, bold science fiction that seeks
to dazzle its viewers, no matter the age,
with visions of planetary destruction and
galactic altruism.
Its end came swiftly, however, and the series
languished in obscurity for years.
Many fans have speculated that the financial
ruin then being faced by Marvel had something
to do with the cartoon's cancellation, as
the series debuted one year after the company
filed for bankruptcy.
Series creator Larry Brody has gone on the
record as saying Silver Surfer fell apart
because of a legal dispute between Marvel
and Saban Entertainment, with scant few details
offered beyond that.
A sleek take on the X-canon, Wolverine and
the X-Men is chock-full of the action, angst,
and adventure that fans of Marvel's mutants
love.
And it took full advantage of the decades
of storytelling it had at its disposal.
"There's a war coming, and it ain't gonna
be pretty."
"I agree.
So, what's next?"
"We bring back the X-Men."
Characters like Dr. Kavita Rao, the Stepford
Cuckoos, and Marrow made their television
debuts as part of the show, while runs like
Joss Whedon and John Cassaday's Astonishing
X-Men served as the basis for the plot.
Though a second season was in production,
it was abruptly scrapped, leaving fans in
the lurch.
Corporate shifts had taken place over the
course of the series' run, chief among them
Disney's purchase of Marvel.
Fox then held the movie rights to the X-Men,
and as fans would come to know, Marvel was
building towards cinematic dominance.
Teams and characters that couldn't contribute
to that effort were automatically of lower
priority, and thus ended Wolverine's time
as the cartoon captain of the X-Men.
The saddest part?
Head writer Greg Johnson has since revealed
that Deadpool was going to be introduced in
the cartoon's second season.
The DC Animated Universe had gone to outer
space before Green Lantern: The Animated Series
debuted, but never quite to the same degree.
After all, Green Lantern's scope is enormous.
The protagonist of the series, Hal Jordan,
is the first human to ever wear the Green
Lantern power ring.
He and his friend, Kilowog, a veteran Lantern,
venture into "Frontier Space" together in
the very first episode, a choice that set
the tone for the rest of the series.
Fans adored the show's wide-open vantage point,
CG aesthetic, and original characters especially
Razer, a Red Lantern out for redemption who
finds himself falling in love with Aya, an
advanced AI.
Despite its passionate fanbase, however, Green
Lantern: The Animated Series was cancelled
after just one season.
Hal Jordan's voice actor, Josh Keaton, spoke
to IGN in the wake of the announcement, acknowledging
fans' anger and the unfortunate cliffhanger
the series now ended on.
The reason behind the cancellation?
From what he'd heard, the so-so performance
of the Green Lantern movie meant that a glut
of movie toys ended up confused for animated
series toys, which translated to stores stocking
less of the latter, depriving the series of
funding.
Ryan Reynolds might've managed to bounce back
from Green Lantern's sorry reception, but
Green Lantern: The Animated Series will remain
a casualty of its failure forever.
The Earth's Mightiest Heroes might've premiered
in 2010, but its heart was classic Marvel.
Though characters like Captain America, Black
Panther, and Ms. Marvel would eventually join
the team, its debut line-up is the same as
the one from 1963's The Avengers #1: Iron
Man, Ant-Man, Hulk, Thor, and the Wasp.
That doesn't mean it confines itself to one
era of Marvel storytelling, though.
Earth's Mightiest Heroes became a beloved
series precisely because it adapted everything
from 2000s comics arcs like "Secret Invasion"
to 1983's beloved "The Ballad of Beta Ray
Bill."
New characters existed seamlessly beside old
ones, while vintage plots were elegantly recalibrated
for younger viewers.
It was, in short, a whole heck of a lot of
fun.
"They appear to be some kind of man-made,
biological life form."
"You say man-made as if you are proud of this."
So when it wasn't renewed for a third season,
fans were upset.
Earth's Mightiest Heroes was scrapped to clear
the way for a new cartoon, Avengers Assemble,
a change Jeph Loeb, head of Marvel Television,
compared to a change of writer on a comic
series.
Avengers Assemble is technically about the
same characters, but it's also a different
cartoon entirely, far more in line with the
MCU.
Though it's fun on its own merits, it's not
Earth's Mightiest Heroes a fact its fans have
had to get used to.
If all X-Men: The Animated Series ever contributed
to the X-Men canon was its killer theme song,
that would've been enough.
But it went above and beyond that sick riff
by adapting many of the X-Men's best stories,
from "Days of Future Past" to the infamous
"Dark Phoenix Saga."
A better introduction to these characters
and their world can scarcely be imagined,
and kids responded in kind, watching the show
in droves.
X-Men: The Animated Series packed five seasons
full to bursting with time travel, cosmic
adventure, and societal turmoil.
And honestly, its end should've arrived much
earlier than it did, as it'd been plagued
with delays and production errors for years,
and the show's run coincided with an era of
financial ruin for Marvel that culminated
in their bankruptcy.
"Better that we die on our feet than live
on our knees."
But the cartoon's success was undeniable.
Despite the fact that the initial series order
had been for 65 episodes, production company
Saban Entertainment decided to extend the
series to 76 episodes.
In that sense, the series is a true rarity:
It was never really cancelled at all.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.